so
we're mixing up the trigonometric
derivatives with the chain rule you can
also mix them up with the product rule
the quotient rule if um you open up to
14g i think it was was what i asked you
to have a look at yesterday
let's have a look at a couple of these
14 g
because we didn't really have time to
actually look at any of those questions
let's have a look at
say where's one i wanted
yeah let's have a look at say 3j do you
see 3j
this is exercise 14g
for those of you who weren't here
yesterday it's the prelim book
um
14g 3 j says y equals
sine x on 1 plus cos x is that right did
i remember that right
yeah that's 3j okay
so here's your u and here's your v just
like a normal quotient
so when i launch into the derivative
v u dash minus u v dash okay let's see
so i'm just going to put down v
1 plus cos x
what's u dash in this case it's on the
board
come on you can all call it out to me i
know it's early but it's like literally
on the board
look carefully
u in this case is sine x
so u dash will be
cos x that's it
it's really easy to get these all mixed
up because of how much they all
look similar okay so there's my v u dash
what does question will have on the
numerator
it's a minus very good negative uh and
then i've got u v dash so here's u
what's v dash here
now be careful again so many little tiny
traps to fall into cos x differentiates
to
negative sine x right so
negative sine x like so and then on my
denominator there's v so 1
plus cos x there's v squared okay now
clearly i can work with this and i can
simplify this quite a bit and so all
your knowledge of trigonometric
identities and even just expanding your
algebra is going to need to come into
play here right so what's my numerator
going to become i can simplify this to
a fair bit right
expensive brackets for me what am i
going to get
i'm going to get a cos first and then
i'm going to get a
cos squared
over here i have a
plus sign squared very good
and hopefully that's that's ringing some
bells for you all divided by 1 plus cos
x
all squared watch out where your
brackets are one of the things that one
of the pieces of feedback that came from
the markers in your ap3 was that
sometimes we just forget brackets and
clearly this
is different to what i wrote on the
previous line right so
don't take shortcuts on that
i can simplify this and that would be
that would totally be a mark like i'm
looking for this to be something that
you recognize right because have a look
at what happens that's
let me write it around in a way that's a
little more helpful so you can see it
right all divided by
one plus cos x squared
now
we have to be more careful with these
things now that they are trigonometric
objects because
there are all kinds of pieces of
trigonometric knowledge which are sort
of assumed in here that you have to be
careful for for example if you saw
something like this 5 over 30 right you
would not skip a heartbeat to say that's
1 out of six right you're like common
factors no big deal there are common
factors here too
i can cancel some what will i end up
with
1 over 1 plus cos x
but you should hold on for a second
right because these things here are not
just numbers like say
five right
one plus cos x is variable right what
you've really done is you've divided by
one plus cos x
on 1 plus cos x can you always divide
by things there is a particular number
you can't just divide pi
because you create problems if you
divide by that number it's only a single
number in the whole universe that causes
problems
it gives you things like vertical
asymptotes when you try to divide by it
you can't divide by
zero right can one plus cos x ever be
zero
one plus cos x oops
can it be zero
and the answer is it totally can right
in fact not only can it be zero it's
zero and infinite number of times right
so
in this case you kind of get out of the
woods you're sort of lucky because if
you think about this what are the
solutions hmm
there's where it is by the way
i'm in calculus mode oh i forgot to
mention this yesterday i said this is
all in radians the very first graph we
did was in radians right
we said oops pi
2 pi why can't this be in degrees i
think i maybe did mention it
why can't this be in degrees
go back to your working yesterday go
back to where we you might hear you just
remember well done go back to working we
were playing around with some limits do
you remember that we were working with
limits we're doing first principles and
at a certain point i think we had
something like this do you remember this
guy do you remember that
now we did something fancy with that we
looked and we said oh that's a mess but
i can say that it's equal to something
simple namely
1 but only if
i'm in radians right so therefore this
has to be in radians the second you said
i'm differentiating or later on if
you're integrating you know it's in
radians
um
when is cos x equal to negative one well
i think erin i heard you say it it's pi
there it is so x can't equal pi
if x were equal to pi in this case then
you're dividing by zero divided by zero
that's a big problem right so in fact
i'm going to have to say that x can't
equal pi
or 3 pi or 5 pi for that matter we'll
come back to that in a bit more detail
later
the reason i said before that you get a
bit lucky here is that there's still a
one plus cos x there okay so it's like
oh i still know that this is true from
what's left behind but if it got
cancelled out that one plus cos x for
example
so this is becoming a bit of a mess
if you had something like this
hmm
that's a bad example
if you had something like this
and you did the same thing right you're
like oh i can cancel right i can cancel
you just get
1 over 10 which i guess we could write
as cot okay can you see now on this line
here i've lost some information right i
no longer realize from this line alone
that x can't equal pi but that was built
into the original question i got rid of
it that was kind of a call that i made
right so
it's still true that x can't equal pi
it's just that it's no longer implied in
this line so you have to be careful just
differentiating trigonometric functions
is more than just cool i have new rules
to use you actually have to think a
little more carefully okay